so this is a classroom a disagreement
breaks out between the student and the
teacher
[Music]
it's able to identifies and they're like
genuinely yeah
you were questioning their identities
I was just saying about the gender I
haven't said anything about them so
different there's only two generals
what the [__] did you say to me Hey
listen bro there's a student that
identifies as a cat and the other
student says hey bro you are unwell you
you you you you you crazy and the
teacher is mad at them for saying
they're crazy
that's the point where teachers are
defending identifying as a cat let's
keep watching
yesterday there's no other toys
Ginger is not linked to do with them
gender is about how you identify which
is why I said right from the very
beginning yeah
okay it's not agenda Hey listen I can't
a cat meow meow meow is not part of
agenda but it is part of the agenda
yeah
students open up your binders today
classes in session girl we are never
gonna let you leave with a lesson
learned you are coming out of the
classroom now snap your fingers do your
step you can do it all by yourself
laughs
[Music]
okay
I call it oatmeal so real be real for
the time has come special real Instagram
likes for all of the liked minded people
have you heard
snap your fingers
[Laughter]
in there
it makes everything cool even if it's
not you know yeah
you identify as a cat meow
now you want to get the pause yeah
hit him with the tail
not least
no no
you try to say bye I say Hello Kitty no
sorry no no I'm sorry the Hello Kitty
that Hello Kitty
get the hook out of here
and female body parts or hormones yeah
you know that yeah
there's three also like biological sets
in terms of gender there are lots of
genders
transgender there is agendic people who
don't believe they have a gender at all
yeah but you can't have that yeah
[Music]
system there is not necessarily the way
to be if you were talking about the fact
that cisgender is the the norm that you
identify with the gender that with the
sexual organ that you're born with or
you're weird that's basically what
you're saying yeah which is really
despicable how well my number
so that's very sad as well then how is
that those people agree with that
there's only a small majority of people
who actually think about and why do you
think we have so many problems in the
world with homophobia what the [__] did
you say I'm so sick of these leaks with
this uh Uganda homophobia's like oh my
God that's one little thing that has
nothing to do with the fact
you you yo yo yo yo yo solving
homophobia is not going to go through
with thinking someone as a cat that's
not how you're gonna solve it that's
just not how you're gonna solve it
accepting that someone says there's a
date their cat and you're gonna be like
their cat homophobia soft that's not how
you're gonna do it I don't even see what
the correlation is how they get in her
head she's thinking people who are not
accepting of the gender ideology are
probably more likely to be homophobic
whatever that's not that's not one thing
what she said but that's the correlation
she's making
you assume yes okay
no now you're cheating there is no link
gender ideology does not have anything
to do with homosexuality lesbianism or
anything else no man no man no man no
man now you're not you see the way they
move the goal posts if you don't accept
all this transgender uh or gender
affirming stuff I identify as a cat
you're also the kind of person who leans
into whole
bruh these people bro and when they say
there's not an agenda when it comes to
these kids you start to hear a lot of
these recordings it's like is this what
they teach their kids in school is this
how they talking to kids because they
don't want to respect someone saying
they're a cat [__]
[Music]
no no you're confusing no I'm not though
and you're confusing gender and sexual
orientation what's your [__] point
don't act like you're the authority
figure on this you might be their
teacher don't mean this you're lame
just because you teach me algebra ain't
to me that you're gonna also be teaching
me physics
ain't me and you won't teach me I marine
biology or anything like that some of
these teachers think they can learn and
teach about everything and you're not
fit to teach this topic apparently you
can't
you can't join them again
no it's not if you don't like it you
need to go to a different school what I
tell you bro remember in the last video
was the one who said you don't belong in
this country with this [__] you've seen
this kind of language yo she can't even
debate them eloquently she just wants
the authority to tell them what to think
this is not a discussion she's saying
this is what it is my opinion is
different that's not an opinion of
course it's an opinion you may not agree
with it but you can't impose that on the
children yo my girls and if you teacher
getting schooled by kids and if you
don't like it you need to go to a
different school yeah think about what
school is meant to be we always talk
about this place of learning the place
where you can challenge with different
ideas no kids come up with their own
opinion or maybe the pain they inherited
whatever it is and instead they're
telling you need to go to a different
school not anymore put you in the box
now when they say there's no
indoctrination or bring watching what is
this that's hard to believe I have never
been one who buys into that kind of
lingo but the more I watch these videos
the more it starts to sound really true
it's hard to believe if you don't like
it you need to go to a different School
God damn because you have an opinion
that's [__] up
[Music]
proper education
conversation
my girl they're doing that right now no
they're not you're you're the one that's
not contributing to that they're trying
to have that conversation right now
that's what they're doing the one that's
failing to have that conversation is you
about about equality diversity because
I'm not having that expressed in my
lesson in the meantime in the meantime
the kid that said I was a cat is in the
corner like meow
diversity inclusion and what equality
diversity inclusion always remember it's
not diversity of thought
no it's diversity of appearance identity
yeah right so people have differing
opinions they're not included we talk
about inclusion but it's inclusion of
people who have the same kind of things
thinking patterns of this and I'm
teaching you about you can be who you
want to be how you identify it is they
just don't say it because
they're polite and maybe they're
sensitive I haven't said anything in all
of the lessons I've been in it's just
because they turn around and started
saying something so I'd say how can you
identify as a cat when you're a girl or
they're now writes in a statement I
would imagine that you'll be asked to
write a statement as well we will these
are nine-year-olds bro yeah
these kids would be like excuse me
that's not gender man that's
I was just being like can I make a
snowball you know like
these kids are having gender they they
yeah but they they School her they
called her yeah yeah I mean these cool
meow I don't know what that person
identify as
but yeah no that's a cat thing that's a
no that's a no we used to meme about
people identifying as an attack
helicopter or a cat but now you got real
teachers trying to be inclusive of these
kinds of ideas it's just a no then you
shouldn't be in school you should be in
a litter box I just want to know if they
can identify anything you want I wonder
if this teacher would accept a white
student identifying as black I wonder I
wonder I wonder I wanna yeah yeah I want
a chicken identify can she identifies A
different race no but she can identify
as a different species
can a grown-ass man identify as a kid
let's troll these people start
identifying as orgasms and screaming
class start identifying as anything bro
I'm serious just just start doing it
what's your identifies a fart
just as juvenile as it is you need to be
disruptive I think this shit's so
[__] stupid when you're saying they
can identify as a cat if it was my
school I remember my school my high
school shout outsy bit back in the days
if it was my high school I swear to God
people would identify as an orgasm being
like oh they uh
every day in this class
what do you I'm just identifying
[Music]
hey yeah
identifies yes daddy Hey listen that's
it for today's topic